[Musique]
citadelle et forteresse caserne et hôtel
tout un patrimoine militaire varié
marque de manière indélébile le paysage
français pourtant méconnu parfois peu
considéré il recèlent des édifices et
monuments d'exception au formes
multiples des trésors cachés de
l'architecture il y a comme une âme ici
les murs transpirent l'histoire et c'est
l'histoire de notre pays il y a une
vraie richesse culturelle une vraie
richesse architecturale aussi tout
autour de nous travailler ici ça ça
oblige un peu en fait à se rappeler
qu'on est de passage et quand on connaît
quelque chose très souvent on finit par
l'aimer
et quand on aime quelque chose on veut
le protéger
[Musique]
depuis des centaines d'années le
ministère des armées occupe des sites
militaires à l'usage et à la typologie
variée toute l'histoire des châteaux et
des fortifications
dont témoignent l'occupation du
ministère des armées mais il y a aussi
des typologies plus emblématiques comme
des palais des hôtels de gouverneur des
lycées militaires qui témoignent aussi
d'une activité des armées qui est pas
seulement défensif mais qui trace un
lien avec l'histoire de la nation le
ministère des armées pour redonner
quelques chiffres c'est d'abord le
premier occupant du domaine public de
l'État avec 23 millions de mètres carrés
occupés bâti et 270 000 hectares de
fonciers et au sein de cet ensemble nous
avons à peu près 120 édifices qui sont
protégés au titre des Monuments
Historiques
[Musique]
en Martinique dans la baie de
Fort-de-France le Fort Saint-Louis
classé en 1973 il est l'une des
forteresses les mieux préservées des
Caraïbes il abrite aujourd'hui la base
navale des forces armées aux Antilles
[Musique]
construit au 17ème siècle le fort est
dit à la Vauban du nom du célèbre
ingénieur du roi Louis XIV qui en
inspire la conception
l'un des concepts de l'ingénieur Vauban
était de laisser les défenseurs du fort
à l'abri des coups et des vues de
l'ennemi Vauban était un humaniste ça ne
se sait pas beaucoup mais c'était
quelqu'un pour qui la vie humaine avait
vraiment un prix il a toujours essayé
que ce soit pendant ses sièges ou
pendant la construction de ses
forteresses de préserver justement le la
vie humaine la vie des soldats
[Musique]
l'apparition de l'artillerie moderne 17e
siècle modifie les manières de faire la
guerre et l'architecture des emprise
militaires
des flèches des épées voire des boulets
enfin des pierres qu'on pouvait envoyer
mais avec l'apparition des boulets en
fonte et là ces grandes murailles ne
tenaient plus et donc il a fallu évoluer
et remplacer ses grandes tours rondes
par des beaucoup plus rapus et non plus
ronde mais triangulaire et qu'on appelle
tout simplement des bastions et on peut
dire que ici on a une architecture de
type bastionnée
le fort contient les ouvrages typiques
d'un système Vauban ces bastions en
pointe qui suppriment les angles morts à
l'intérieur un chemin couvert pour
surveiller sans être vu
des Courtilles nous sont positionnés des
canons
d'autres vestiges témoignent des
aménagements du fort au fil des siècles
là ici nous sommes donc dans cette
partie du fort ou on va pouvoir
approvisionner en munitions les
différentes batteries qui ont été
rajoutées à la fin du 19e siècle au
moment de l'épisode de la guerre fin de
de Fachoda en Égypte avec les Anglais et
donc du coup on a préféré renforcer la
défense de Fort-de-France on l'a de
temps de moyens d'artillerie moderne
pour renforcer la ligne de défense
française autour de Fort de France deux
autres édifices sont bâties sur les
hauteurs de la ville
le fort 2aies au XVIIIe siècle et le
fort tartançon au 19e siècle
tartançons et cédé à la ville de
Fort-de-France en 2009 dans le cadre
d'un projet touristique
la vocation militaire est défensive
stratégique des forts en fond des lieux
méconnus des trésors cachés
effectivement donc c'est important d'en
ouvrir les portes et de retranscrire une
histoire
qui n'est pas seulement militaire mais
qui est celle de la construction d'une
société d'un paysage et de le prolonger
dans l'avenir ici la ville a proposé
dans son programme de développer ce site
de l'ouvrir sur la ville avec un circuit
de promenade pour en faire un lieu
citoyen un espace mémoriel mais aussi on
aura des espaces de compréhension
d'efforts le fort tartançon l'effort de
Fort-de-France l'effort de la Caraïbe
c'est adossé un projet de création d'une
route des fins de la Caraïbe qui partira
de Cuba jusqu'à la Martinique
perché sur le ment Garnier le fort de
Zay et le siège du commandement
supérieur des forces armées aux Antilles
et du 33e régiment d'infanterie de
marine
inscrit au titre des Monuments
Historiques en 2009 il est radié en 2011
pour devenir un centre d'entraînement
la vocation du régiment est avant tout
et du site de V est avant tout la
guérissement des unités et pour pouvoir
opérer monter des infrastructures
artificielles telles que les obstacles
les plus commando a demandé à ce qu'il
soit dépassé
lui aussi un fort à la Vauban la plus
imposante fortification de ce type en
Martinique l'architecture est encore
bien visible les demi-lune par exemple
qui servaient à couvrir les bastions
l'escarpe et la Contrescarpe de murs de
terre défensifs
ces galeries inclinées qui relient le
fossé et l'intérieur du fort alors vous
êtes ici en direction de la courtine
Ouest
plus particulièrement au pied de la
poterne ouest là aussi on part des
douves on remonte à l'intérieur du Ford
donc la poterne Ouest
quoi particulier cette poterne est
d'origine puisque elle est équipée comme
c'était de portes en haut en bas de
porte en bois rouge très solide et à
l'intérieur bijoux de l'architecture
c'est la plus belle des une calade qui
permettait aux sabot une bête de somme
les chevaux de
d'agripper pour grimper à l'intérieur du
four
la préservation d'un tel lieu en l’état
est un vrai défi d'autant plus en
Martinique nous sommes tous les
tropiques pluie soleil à la repousse
végétale est exorbitante un service de
génie de l'époque d'aide du 148 se
plaignait déjà qu'il n'y arrivait pas
donc c'est un travail de longue haleine
répétitif sur lequel on ne doit pas
lâcher pour tenir ce joyau ce joyau à
l'état c'est le patrimoine de la
Martinique c'est donc c'est un joyeux
culturel et architectural qu'il faut
absolument préserver préserver et mettre
à disposition du public
la particularité de ces sites du Fort
Saint-Louis
et de forteset c'est qu'ils sont dans la
ville
alors on dit que le fort de Z est un peu
en hauteur mais en fait il est quand
même dans la ville comment voulez-vous
ne pas faire bénéficier à la population
un patrimoine qui leur appartient
également donc on l'ouvre on a organisé
on a mis en place des modalités d'accès
mais les deux forces sont accessibles
évidemment pendant les journées du
patrimoine mais pas seulement justement
pour faire bénéficier à la population de
ces deux sites historiques exceptionnels
un peu et donc il y a de la route le
Fort Saint-Louis accueille régulièrement
des scolaires comme ces deux classes de
quatrième et troisième du collège Roger
Castanet situé à Fort-de-France
vous retrouver le phare de la pointe des
une fois cette fortification se
dit bah oui il y a eu des choses ici
c'est pas c'est des choses et c'est ce
que l'on transmet et c'est ce que
j'essaye de transmettre en accueillant
plus de 4500 jeunes et moins jeunes
parents ça leur permet de connaître
ce fond et quand on connaît quelque
chose très souvent on finit par l'aimer
et quand on aime quelque chose on veut
le protéger et là il y a toute une
action à mener pour voir bien laisser un
héritage faire perdurer ce patrimoine
vers les générations futures
avant la Révolution française on
démolissait on reconstruisait au fur et
à mesure c'est comme ça que vous avez
des châteaux ou des églises qui sont de
plusieurs périodes on s'occupait pas
d'avoir quelque chose qui est une unité
et le passé n'avait pas d'importance à
part est une carrière de pierre la
Révolution française et le systématisme
des dégradations a créé un choc qui fait
que quand la France a retrouvé une
certaine stabilité elle a regardé ses
déduit ses destructions en disant j'ai
perdu quelque chose qu'on a nommé un
patrimoine et c'est à ce moment là que
c'est développé un sentiment de
et l'idée de conserver ce patrimoine
comme une mémoire du passé et donc il y
a eu des lois sur les monuments
historiques et il y a eu des lois sur
les sites au sens paysage patrimoniaux
et donc un site c'est un paysage
patrimonial qui peut contenir du bâti et
un monument historique c'est surtout du
bâti même si ça peut être étendu à
Desjardins et à des choses comme ça le
château de Versailles est protégé au
titre des monuments historiques et dans
l'idée de Versailles il y avait
l'horizon à perte de vue toute la plaine
de Versailles et protégée par un site
classé donc c'est des centaines de
hectares sur lesquels il toutes les
constructions sont interdites mais dans
le but de protéger la vue jusqu'à
l'infini depuis le château
[Musique]
pas de vue dégagée pour le pritané
national militaire mais comme le château
de Versailles une architecture du 17e
siècle remarquable et des murs chargés
d'histoire
cet établissement militaire situé en
plein cœur de la flèche dans la Sarthe
prépare aujourd'hui au baccalauréat et
au concours d'entrée aux grandes écoles
militaires
[Musique]
vous êtes dans un lieu effectivement
emblématique et comme disent les élèves
séculaires qui dont l'histoire des
marais en 1604 sous Henri IV avec ce
fameux Fouquet de la Varenne qui
construit ce collège jésuite aux ordres
d'Henri IV qui devient ensuite école
royale puis ensuite école impérium en
passant par des phases des soirs
l'histoire de France pour arriver à
arriver effectivement en 1808 arrivé la
dénomination par Napoléon Bonaparte de
prytaner national militaires c'est le
seul prix tonné sur l'ensemble des 6
lycées de défense en tout cas qui porte
ce nom et qui effectivement est
emblématique puisque 400 ans d'histoire
nous contemple ce qui n'est pas rien on
est effectivement très impressionné
quand on prend ce genre d'établissement
je pense qu'il faut être très humble
donc si on peut apporter entre
guillemets un peu notre pierre édifice
le temps de d'un incommodement voilà à
chaque fois on a on a effectivement
énormément d'émotions à traverser ces
lieux emblématiques
vous l'avez senti en arrivant dans ce
lieu
il respire l'histoire de France depuis
ses origines
à la fin du sixième siècle la flèche est
une petite cité qui très empreinte de
l'esprit médiéval à peine 5000 hommes et
il faut imaginer cette décision royale
du roi Henri IV de fonder ici un collège
de Jésus on va mettre en place ici une
architecture exceptionnelle qui donc la
construction ont d'ailleurs va c'est se
dérouler sur plus d'un demi siècle mais
qui ne sera pas sans influencer la
transformation du paysage urbain très
médiéval alors
le prytané s'étend sur près de 30
hectares il est constitué de deux
quartiers principaux Henri IV et
Gallieni du nom du maréchal de France
Joseph Gallieni le collège de Jésus de
la flèche est construit dans la première
moitié du 17e siècle ils organisent en
trois cours principal la cour des
pensionnaires première campagne de
construction la cour des classes et la
cour royale qu'en cadre a laissé à
l'ouest de les cours d'importance
moindre affectés au service de
l'établissement et l'ensemble est dominé
par la masse imposante de l'église
Saint-Louis
[Musique]
le lieu est partiellement protégé au
titre des Monuments Historiques son
portail d'honneur et les glisse Saint
Louis ou sont conservés les cendres du
cœur du roi Henri IV sont classés en
1919 les toitures et les façades de
l'ancien collège des Jésuites sont
inscrites en 1933 à l'inventaire
supplémentaire
cette inscription sera étendue plus
récemment en 1994 à l'ensemble de l'aile
sud de la cour d'honneur c'est dire que
l'ensemble de ceci fut égare l'intérêt
architectural lié à cette histoire et
bien et protégé au titre des Monuments
Historiques j'ai moi-même assisté à ces
travaux de restauration nombreux comment
en particulier la restauration des nefs
l'église Saint-Louis à la fin des années
1980 nous avons au début de la première
décennie des années 2000 la restauration
de la tour de pierre qui se trouve
derrière moi et tout à fait récemment et
bien la restauration d'une part du
Campanile qui domine la croupe
de l'église Saint-Louis
le financement de la restauration du
Campanile a été partagée pour moitié
avec le ministère de la Culture une
opération inscrite dans le cadre d'un
protocole d'accord signé en 2019 qui
encadre la réalisation des travaux sur
les monuments historiques classés
appartenant aux armées
Charlemagne les élèves de
l'établissement sans qu'il y a dans ce
lieu quelque chose de particulier qu'on
ne retrouve certainement nulle part
ailleurs il y a comme une âme ici les
murs transpirent l'histoire et c'est
l'histoire de notre pays de grands
hommes qui ont servi notre pays ont
étudié dans cette maison et ils ont
repris donc le contrôle de cette
frontière de nombreuses personnes sont
passées par ici comme par exemple le tri
célèbre philosophe Descartes et à ce
moment on peut se dire que on a quelque
chose en plus de dire ce passage au sein
du prytanet National Militaire c'est
vrai que c'est motivant on se dit que
ils ont réussi on peut tous réussir dans
nos vies et ça nous motive de se dire
que c'est un tremplin un peu pour pour
nos vies de d'être ici c'est une chance
qu'on rentre dans notre lycée par la
porte principale on aperçoit un grand
bâtiment avec le créateur Gallieni qui a
lui aussi un matricule et
dès cette dès les premiers pas d'entrer
dans le lycée on voit que ce lycée est
chargé d'histoire on est
dans un cadre exceptionnel tout
simplement
dès qu'un monument est classé au titre
de la protection des monuments
historiques il faut des autorisations
spéciales de travaux qui sont délivrés
par le préfet de la région compétente et
on a l'obligation de recourir à un
architecte en chef des Monuments
historiques comme maître d'Off des
travaux de restauration sur l'édifice
donc c'est à la fois un gage de sécurité
de sérieux de solidité des projets qu'on
porte mais ça aussi un coût et il faut
aussi réussir à l'assumer ce que le
ministère de des armées essaye de faire
[Musique]
l'avenue Foch à Lyon en Rhône-Alpes
abrite un haut lieu de commandement
classés au titre des monuments
historiques le Cabinet du Gouverneur
militaire
[Musique]
construit au XIXe siècle cet hôtel
discret fait partie des plus anciens
bâtiments gérés par les ides
l'établissement du service
d'infrastructures de la défense de Lyon
dont le parc immobilier couvre toute la
région Sud-Est
le site est inscrit depuis 2014 au
patrimoine des monuments de France et il
a été classé en 2015 donc tout l'aspect
extérieur mais également à l'intérieur
du bâtiment
[Musique]
seul le passant attentif peut le
constater il manque trois fenêtres à la
façade elles ont été envoyées chez un
artisan de la région pour être restauré
accompagné d'un cahier des charges
précis faut savoir que l'hôtel le
gouverneur militaire a été construit au
19e siècle avec le savoir-faire des
artisans de l'époque faut faire le point
avec les entreprises actuelles pour
qu'elles reprennent exactement l'origine
et qu'elle garde l'origine de ce fenêtre
et les fenêtres qu'on restaure sont en
bois c'est du chêne les fenêtres ne sont
pas remplacées elles sont bien reprises
à l'identique donc pour cela il y a eu
un certain nombre de diagnostics de
prélèvements par exemple de la couleur
d'origine des fenêtres qui ont été
réalisées ensuite un protocole a été
élaboré pour ensuite pouvoir restaurer
les fenêtres en atelier et uniquement la
pose se fera à l'hôtel du gouverneur
militaire malgré toutes les contraintes
qu'on peut retrouver administratives du
fait du de la valeur patrimoniale du
bâtiment c'est très intéressant de
travailler sur l'hôtel du gouverneur
militaire c'est des bâtiments qu'on
retrouve peu en province hormis dans les
grandes villes Lyon Marseille donc c'est
toujours des technicités à part des
savoir-faire qui sont différents du ce
qu'on peut retrouver au quotidien sur
des bâtiments militaires classiques
l'hôtel a été construit entre 1858 et
1861 dans le style bourgeois du Second
Empire pour le baron Jonas Vita banquier
et marchand de soie lyonnais d'origine
piémontaise
il est racheté par la ville de Lyon en
1913 pour y installer les gouverneurs
militaires
tout commence en fait sous le porche
avec ses caissons à volutes qui sont des
questions typiquement renaissances pour
rappeler pour rappeler l'Italie la
grande Italie de la Renaissance
lorsqu'on rentre dans la cour de l'hôtel
qui est une cour assez somptueuse avec
de très belles arcades de part et
d'autre côté nord côté sud 12 arcades
successives surmontés d'une terrasse qui
permettait de profiter à la fois du
soleil et du calme de l'intérieur et
puis on va retrouver aussi comme élément
typique de l'Italie de très jolies
fontaines qui sont en béton moulés des
premiers béton moulés de l'époque
surmonter de Conques qui rappellent
encore une fois la qui rappelle encore
une fois la Renaissance on retrouve
aussi à l'intérieur de l'hôtel un
certain nombre d'éléments d'architecture
mais qui sont un peu plus discrets on
retrouve un très bel élément sur
l'origine espagnole dans le fumoir avec
de très belles tapisseries en cuir de
Cordoue puisque la famille le bassin de
la famille Vita et l'Espagne
[Musique]
l'hôtel Vita est un lieu assez secret
c'est un lieu de pouvoir entouré de
mystère très clairement c'est à dire que
les habitants historiques du cinéma
arrondissement de Lyon connaissent peu
ce lieu même s'il est effectivement
ouvert depuis de nombreuses années
aujourd'hui européenne du patrimoine
[Musique]
travailler ici ça oblige un peu en fait
à se rappeler qu'on est de passage et
que et que le gouverneur passe cet hôtel
et l'hôtel des gouverneurs jusqu'à ce
qu'on décide de le quitter et nous
sommes dans une longue transmission dans
une longue histoire il y a un respect
évidemment des pierres et puis il y a
une beauté particulière qui est la
beauté du passé
un sentiment partagé par un fervent
défenseur du patrimoine français
Stéphane Bern
on parle toujours du patrimoine on pense
que c'est des pierres c'est un peu mort
mais non derrière ces pierres il y a des
gens et et moi c'est ce qui m'importe
quand je sauve des pierres je sauve la
mémoire des gens et c'est aussi
important
je crois justement que le patrimoine est
un lien essentiel
le lieu crédulien et c'est un lien entre
les Français et l'armée
réservistes citoyens à la gendarmerie
nationale par un du 40e régiment de
transmission de Thionville l'animateur
est aussi propriétaire depuis 2012 d'un
ancien collège royal et militaire celui
de Tyron Gardet dans le Perche
parce qu'il tombe en ruine le
département d'Eure-et-Loir décide à
l'époque de le vendre à moindre coût en
échange Stéphane Bern s'engage à le
réhabiliter et à l'ouvrir au public
il y en avait 12 en France adossé le
plus part du temps à des abbayes vous
voyez encore les restes de l'abbaye de
Tiron du 12e siècle 1114 exactement ce
collège a été créé en 1630 c'est un
collège religieux et puis ensuite Louis
XVI avec son ministre de la guerre le
comte de Saint-Germain a décidé de faire
des classes préparatoires qui
préparaient les élèves les enfants
d'officiers et de nobles et bien à faire
l'École royale militaire qui est devenue
notre école militaire à Paris donc on
est très fiers d'avoir préparé des de
prestigieux militaires
les présidents de la République ont
choisi de confier au ministère des
armées de vivifier ce lien armé avec la
nation puisque une armée c'est pas
seulement des gens qui vont se battre
pour vous mais il faut que c'est un sens
et nous sommes une institution qui plus
que d'autres avaient besoin que ce sens
et cette confiance et cette solidité
soit tissée et maintenue entre tous nos
concitoyens et les forces armées et nous
nous servons d'un certain nombre de de
place forte ou de lieux emblématiques
pour comme appui en faveur et aux
bénéfice d'un lien arménation
[Musique]
c'est le cas du Mont Valérien campé sur
les hauteurs de Suresnes dans les Hauts
de Seine il abrite depuis 1947 le 8e
régiment de transmission
mais c'est d'abord un lieu de culte
médiéval avant de devenir une forteresse
militaire au 19e siècle
plus tard pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale il est utilisé par l'armée
allemande comme lieu d'exécution
un peu plus de 1000 résistants et otages
y sont fusillés entre 1941 et 1944
parmi eux il y a des figures célèbres
donc d'Estienne d'Orves Gabriel Péri et
bien d'autres qui ont qui ont perdu la
vie ici exécutés par les Allemands donc
et à ce titre là le Mont Valérien est
devenu un haut lieu de la mémoire
française et
peu après la guerre donc le général de
Gaulle en a fait un symbole de la
résistance
la flamme de la résistance ne
s'attradera jamais quoi qu'il arrive
c'est écrit sur le frontispice de du
Mémorial de la France combattante qui
est situé en contrebas de la forteresse
et sur lequel viennent tous les 18 juin
et président de la République au cours
d'une cérémonie
travailler ici c'est pénétrer dans un
lieu
littéralement chargé d'histoire c'est
quelque part saluer toute cette histoire
qui a traversé les siècles cette
histoire militaire cette histoire
nationale cette histoire de mémoire
aussi Qui est qui est entretenu et
valorisé ici il y a une vraie richesse
culturelle une vraie richesse
architecturale aussi tout autour de nous
[Musique]
le Mont Valérien est inscrit en totalité
au titre des monuments historiques il
abrite plusieurs œuvres d'architecte
comme le mémorial un mur de 150 mètres
engrais rose des Vosges qui portent 16
au relief de bronze créé par autant de
sculpteurs des illustrations de la
France au combat de 1939 à 1945 et au
centre une croix de Lorraine de 12
mètres de haut ou encore cette cloche de
bronze recouverte des noms des fusillés
du Mont Valérien
ce lieu unique est aujourd'hui un outil
de transmission de la mémoire et du
souvenir le Mont Valérien accueille de
nombreux visiteurs chaque année la
moitié sont des scolaires comme ces
élèves de CM2 de l'école Paul Bert de
Bois-Colombes
l'idée c'est de leur faire découvrir ce
lieu d'exécution qui est le principal
lieu d'exécution de la région parisienne
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
donc de leur transmettre l'histoire et
la mémoire de ses hommes et de visiter
aussi le mémorial de la France
combattante où sont inhumés des
personnes que l'on au nord pour leur
engagement qui ont participé à la
défense du pays et qui ont voilà lutter
pour que la France soit libre le dernier
avoir été inhumé dans la crypte c'est
Hubert Germain en novembre 2021 qui
était en fait un homme qui a rejoint le
général de Gaulle suite à son appel du
18 juin et qui a été honoré comme 1037
autres personnes ils étaient 1038 à
devenir des Compagnons de la Libération
et donc Hubert Germain était le dernier
de ce groupe encore en vie il avait été
décidé que le dernier compagnon de la
Libération rejoindrait la crypte ils
sont trois en compagnon la libération
Alfred Touny un autre homme et une des
six femmes compagnons Berty Albrecht
aussi
pour ses élèves la visite du Mont
Valérien et l'étape finale d'un projet
pédagogique d'un an autour de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale qui a débuté sur les
plages du débarquement
mais c'est un vrai devoir de mémoire
qu'on est là donc effectivement
comprendre ce qui s'est passé pendant la
guerre quand ils viennent dans des sites
comme c'est là où effectivement ils se
retrouvent dans la crypte il voit qu'il
y a des gens qui qui représentent tous
les résistants aux quatre coins du monde
et qui ont lutté pour pour libérer le
pays ils se disent ah oui c'est vrai ça
a vraiment existé c'est pas que des
pages dans un livre d'histoire c'est pas
que des dires d'un enseignant c'est
vraiment des choses qui se sont passées
des choses essentielles et du coup ils
prennent je pense qu'ils prennent
conscience effectivement de cette
importance là
le patrimoine militaire est tout à la
fois un témoin privilégié du passé un
outil de mémoire et de transmission un
lien tissé entre la nation et ses armées
le ministère des armées s'attache à
préserver cet héritage en jeu majeur de
notre histoire et de notre culture
[Musique]